علاقه بارده تجمع الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب بزعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه في
مجلس الشيوخ متشمكونال تشعلها ملاسمه لا
تنتهي وان كانت حده لهجتها اخف من ناحيه
السيناتور
التشريعيه لكن الفجوه تتسعت بعد خساره
ترامب للانتخابات عام 2020 وقت الحمل
انصاره للكونغرس
لتبدا المعركه بانتقادات لشخص مكونال
ومكانته الوظيفيه فترامب اكد عجز الحزب
الجمهوري عن كسب الاحترام او الفوز مجددا
بقياده السياسيين مثل ماكونال العابث وفق
تعبيره محملا اياه مسؤوليه فقدان الاغلبيه
بمجلس الشيوخ
[موسيقى]
دعوه ترامب شبه المتواصله لاستبدال مكان
الكزعيم للجمهوريين يدعمها احيانا
بتغريدات ساخره على موقعه للتواصل
الاجتماعي تروسوس ووصفت بالمحرضه على
العنف حين انتقد موافقه ماكونل على صفقه
لتمويل الحكومه مضيفا ان لديه رغبه في
الموت
ولم تتوقف صوله الرئيس السابق وجولته
عندما كان لنفسه بل تخططه للاستخفاف
بزوجته المولوده بتعيبان ووصفها بالمحبه
للصين فصول المواجهه الثنائيه جاءت ضربتها
اكثر تحفظا من جانب ماكونال الذي التزم
الصمت تجاه تغريدات ووصف اداء ترامب
بالمجنونه ورغم ان ما كان لا اعتبر ترامب
مسؤولا عمليا واخلاقيا عن اثاره احداث
الكونجرس الا انه لم يصوت لاذاته
ليش موقع
ين الذين يدعمهم ترامب بالانتخابات
النصفيه مؤكدا انهم سيزيدون صعوبه استعاده
السيطره على مجلس الشيوخ وتحقيقه انجازا
جديدا يتمثل بصاحب اطول فتره خدمه فيها